I have a recommendation for you today a
documentary that's going to be
controversial in that there are people
who are going to really like this
recommendation in like the film if they
watch it I predict but there are also
people who are going to hate that I'm
even recommending this film I'm talking
about a documentary film called The Mask
you live in and what this film explores
is what is perceived by the producer of
the documentary to be harmful notions
about masculinity in American culture
this looks at up different aspects of
how American culture deals with
masculinity and how it affects
specifically young boys and young men as
they become adult males in American
society now there are going to be some
men's rights activists and so called
anti feminists who hate the movie and
hate that I'm recommending it because
they'll say oh it in accurately
represents what are not the real issues
for men and boys in our society uh
however there are some men's rights
activists and anti feminists who are
probably going to really like this film
because they say hey finally someone is
taking a look at issues affecting men
and boys in a world that according to
many men's rights activists an
anti-feminist a world that according to
them ignores men and boys as victims
focusing only on uh some some of them
believe women some of them believe
minorities irrespective of gender etc I
believe that there is a lot that is
really worthwhile in this film there are
some aspects of the film that are less
good for example i think that the
critique that this film espouses
probably doesn't pay as much attention
as it should do to a jew to not to jews
but to racial dynamics involved in some
of the identified issues i think that
that's a fair criticism of the film but
i would really recommend watching it one
of the experts that is interviewed in
the film philip zimbardo is actually
someone we interviewed on the show some
time ago so if you want check out the
documentary which is on netflix it's
so on amazon and you can check it out
link to it uh and also check out all of
my other recommendations for books
documentaries TV shows all sorts of
stuff a growing list a dynamic and
robust list at david pakman.com slash
recommendations of course anything that
you stream or buy through david
pakman.com slash recommendations will
send a little kick back to the show if
you purchase it or stream it through
amazon the mask we live in i think that
it at the math you live in rather i
think it is an excellent documentary
aside from whether I agree with every
point that it makes and I I would love
it if some people in our audience
particularly those who maybe have more
of a sympathy towards so-called men's
rights activism or skeptical of feminism
tell me what you think about it I think
again there will be some who like it and
some who feel that it misses the mark